i saw the other day
iphone came out with a new thing they
announced that any small app companies
with revenues less than a million
dollars they're going to lower
the 33 to i think the number was 10 or
15 percent
and you know anybody above a million
dollars are still keeping the third so
if you do
10 million on apps they want to keep the
3.3 million dollars and
you keep the 6.7 million dollars and we
were sitting on having a conversation on
the podcast
and uh i sat there and i said look what
a great net
apple has created if you want music you
got to go through itunes if you want to
download an app you pretty much got to
go through itunes if you want to do
you know group text and put a thumbs up
and you're droid i'm not
you know i'm apple you can't get the
thumbs up right and
if you want to you know send a uh a
group text sometimes even in a group
text a droid on an iphone
the group doesn't go out if you want to
do there's so many different things that
you look at with the net that they've
done
my biggest concern becomes as i look at
the market share i pulled this up you're
the expert here i'm curious what you
think about it
2020 q3 market share u.s i have usn have
worldwide in front of me worldwide it's
a different
story but in us apple's got 40 percent
by the way q2 sales was 46
and samsung was 25 so if you look at the
numbers it's
relatively 46 percent 25
samsung 12 lg then it's seven percent
lenovo
then it's 10 others right so you got
huawei and whatever other phones that
may be
you know minus the uh sanction that they
have you go worldwide
samsung's at the top so i'm not going
worldwide i'm going specifically in the
us
how does somebody compete with apple
and smartphone in the us how do you take
market share away from them i mean they
have you
type in so i mean you're locked in you
got to have an iphone
how do you beat those guys yeah you know
they've they've built up
and i did a video about this called just
the ecosystem they've built up
not just the iphone which has obviously
a pretty big head start on a lot of
other people trying to get market share
but they've built up
products that are great products that
are tied to the iphone i'm wearing an
apple watch right now
in my opinion it's the best smart watch
you can buy it's only available
if you have an iphone air pods are some
of the most popular headphones on earth
that you can only really get the most
value out of if you use an iphone
and it just keeps going and going their
other products they all tie into this
ecosystem
and so it turns out if you want to
compete with apple
on market share of the phone you have to
compel
not just people to switch to your phone
but people to switch to your ecosystem
of products
that are tied to the phone which they're
all starting to do you know you see
other wireless headphone competitors you
see other
services competitors some even do things
that apple doesn't do
like when you look at google's pixel
line you start to see google photos
integration you start to see other
google services plugged in more tightly
but at the end of the day there's a lot
of people already in apple's ecosystem
who even if they could switch for free
probably wouldn't because they're just
so happy with
the products that they've all tied in um
so it's tough you got it you got to
really make a compelling
series of reasons for them to switch to
a bunch of other products instead of
just getting rid of the iphone because
getting rid of the iphone means getting
rid of a lot of stuff
which one of the which one of the nets
or which one of the
parts elements of the ecosystem do you
think
locks in the most users you think it's
the apps you think it's more the
hardware you know like the
the watch what do you think it is that
locks us into into apple
in the us it's definitely imessage uh
and i see this uh
as far like if i put my sim card in an
iphone i
carry an iphone specifically because i
have imessage only contacts people who
just use imessage
uh it's not so much the case worldwide
if you look at like you mentioned all
the other areas they buy phones just
based on the hardware like
huawei is gigantic sure in china because
people don't
necessarily care about the iphone's
hardware and imessage is not really
useful to them so
in the us it's for sure imessage uh then
i think you might see some pull from
like just hardware accessories
you know the the headphones the the
cases the apps
the app store is obviously a huge one
but i think it's imessage here